let's go to our caller from the 3:05
area code maybe from I think 305 is
Miami love Miami if that's where you're
calling from if not I still love Miami
you're just you're just not calling from
there 305 305 are you there at all let's
start there hello that is you how are
you good are we we're not on
speakerphone are we no oh boy all right
go ahead I have a question for you and
now I make a quick point though my
question is I it really should be a
chant boy sorry well you're you're
breaking up I don't know if we're on
Bluetooth or if you have a bad signal
but you're breaking up can you can you
ask your question one more time can you
hear me hello yes go ahead so we should
Democrats focus on helping Joe Manchin
win the election like Joe magic to me
needs to this I think Joe Manchin is a
disaster for the Democratic Party yep
like he's the only Democrat copying by
supporting Trump and turning turning she
voted for Cavanaugh I really don't think
he should be a sinner anymore and I'm
willing to lose control of the Senate if
that means you lose mansion okay see now
you go so here's the thing we the
Democratic Party needs to replace
mansion or should we are you willing to
lose hold on a second
should we be willing to lose control of
the Senate when so much is riding on the
control of the Senate right now I think
the answer is no now you might say well
if mansions just going to vote for
Republicans you might have control of
the Senate on paper but not in reality
he's not gonna vote with Republicans on
everything so I feel that we should not
say we don't care about control the
Senate if it means mansion loses and a
Republican wins but there needs to be a
plan for getting trying to get a real
Democrat in but you've got to remember
mansions in West Virginia is there any
other kind of Democrat that could win I
don't know the answer well Bernie
Sanders from all the precincts in West
Virginia and
I think that we can win Texas I think we
could win the mississippi special
election so I'm not really worried about
mansion winning and I really do my
civilan to win because she vote 61% were
timeless Trump and she's kind of now a
we're Democrats same with Radisson I do
think that maybe we'll think important
upset and I think David bill he's laying
in Mississippi against Roger look I
think he has a chance because Roger
wicker has really been doing one point
he's like in the 47 wage right yeah
listen we're getting about eight races I
think the mansion question though to
focus on that is an interesting one but
I don't want to lose control of the
Senate right now by replacing mansion
with a Republican but mansions have
major problem hey well I didn't catch
your name what was your name oh I'm
sorry my name is Paul Paul okay alright
I appreciate the call Paul thank you so
much yeah paddy what you had a thought
on this oh well I'd rather have mansion
who votes with Trump's 60% of the time
than some Republican votes menus gonna
vote with Trump ninety-five percent of
time and the time to primary Joe Manchin
has passed Paula Jean Swearengen ran
against them and lost yes this is what
we have so far is here Joe Manchin or a
Republican and and you also have to
remember would it would have further
left Democrat win in West Virginia I
don't know the answer I'm not I'm not
saying this I'm not playing the least of
to Eva I'm just asking the question is
there a different type of Democrat that
could win right now in West Virginia and
I don't know the answer to that